here in Stockholm nice to be here
how are you I'm great just started
filming again you know second season
Lillehammer and as you as as you've
probably been told because Lillehammer
is is a huge success in norway in and in
sweden is with the television series and
also in america yeah very unusual do we
have a different approach to work here
compared to America
yeah like compared to Sopranos why are
you very different very different it's
actually civilized here I know I'm in
Norway yeah I'm sure here too uh we work
in America on TV like 6:00 a.m. to 10:00
p.m. every night and then Friday like
forget it because there's no 12-hour
turn around so you work until like 6:00
the next morning it's ridiculous and you
know we there's no life you have no life
at all you know and you get used to it
so it was a shock when you come here and
you're back you're done at 6 o'clock
it's like wow well I dunno you know I
have a well that's even to our over time
you know Oh 6 o'clock is quite late
actually I guess I'll get somebody in
trouble yeah no it's it's very very nice
to actually live you know I'm really a
crazy workaholic anyway you know but but
uh it's nice to have a little so so what
you're saying is that the difference is
that we have a life you have a life
you're you have rules that you actually
follow America we don't have many rules
and the ones we do we break you know it
but the other difference is it's very do
it yourself you know Norwegian culture
is very very do it yourself I saw one
stuntman in six months you know in six
months of war you have to you have to do
their stuff in yeah and and and it was a
scene if you remember we cut a hole in
the ice cuz the guy owed me money and
we're gonna dunk him in the water you
know and we dunk the guy in the water
you know with the stuntman the Sun man
got dressed in a wetsuit
went in the water and soon as we're done
the actor jumped in I did this I did
this start anyway so we didn't even need
the ones that man you know it's a very
different kind of woman like so many
people you know well no it's quite five
million people you know we have to do
things I'm sorry he was used to swim in
the cold waters maybe that's really nice
you know you should write your say I'll
never know
calm down this man you know he is
Finland's Tony Soprano he's he's
finished and you know they they always
they spend their time in the soma for in
the very cold water so that's the sort
of in and out under the eyes are your
soul you're a solo man yeah yeah
absolutely
I'm doing it tonight no not with me you
are and I I think that and looking back
on your career you you very often you've
been the consigliere you've been to
Tony's a problem that that's the party
played it when and but also I I suspect
Bruce Springsteen you've been very
important also as an adviser and as a
friend yeah we I think kind of modeled
the Silvio character a little bit after
my own relationship with Bruce a little
bit you know the part you played in
surprise party Sopranos of being the
console getting to to Tony Soprano his
best friend that he grew up with you
know it's kind of modeled after my
relationship with Bruce yeah
so how did the drifts appreciate being
at all his problem he really is the holy
Fred
in real life uh you know I I am I am
very comfortable and I always have been
very comfortable behind the scenes and
being more of a band guy the ensemble
guy more in a producer role or writer
role you know then um star and front guy
you know I never really wanted to be a
front guy or star or an actor or I never
thought about it you know would you
would you characterize yourself as a
good advisor oh good no I really am
because not because I'm smart because
I'm so stupid I have done everything
wrong in my life you could possibly do
yeah it's exactly which makes us good
advisors right
we tell somebody to do something we're
talking from experience can you show
them the skies yeah because we did the
opposite right we did the wrong thing
and you know don't do it like I did you
know well it makes you a very good a
very good advisor would you be a good
divisor learner see how quiet I am
and in some cases yes so what's the best
advice you can give a young actress
coming good hey you actor come here what
is it yeah let's say this your master is
coming to you for advice what can you
say at a practice the practice you have
some little bit of talent and then it's
hard work that's it do people come to
you for a lot be yourself that's good
advice
after all the bad advice we are being
giving be yourself and accept that you
can always try save all the mistakes but
the first first be yourself doesn't
doesn't that you live depend on who you
are oh no depending will be all
intelligent people but we make stupid
decisions from time to time and that's
why I say try to find out what who you
are and behaviors yourself that's the
advice I give I'm speaking of stars we
have Steven
we have Miguel here tonight and he's
really a shooting I just
I just met him yeah yeah yeah um I
wonder if you were to give him one
advice mmm for the future because it's
really there where you know he's a B you
know it depends on what mood I'm in at
the time but most of the time I tell
people if you need advice you're not
gonna make it
okay
it sounds harsh but you know what I mean
if you're depending on somebody patting
you on the back it's a good nice job
we're all behind you and we're gonna
support you forget it you have to have
that strength in yourself or you're not
gonna make it any less Rock speed a
peaceful community poder
you